el reconocimiento del monarca como
cabeza de la common Wells no es
hereditario los miembros deben
ratificarlo todos los estados de la
agrupación tienen al monarca como jefe
de estado o cuántos de ellos lo tienen
Cuál es el papel del monarca como jefe
de esta institución
bien son 56 países los miembros de la
commonwealth fundada en 1949 recordemos
que Isabel segunda suma en 1952 es decir
que a lo largo de todo su reinado la
organización fue creciendo punto junto
con ella prácticamente no conoce a otro
monarca como bien decía hasta un 14 los
países que reconocen a Isabel como la
como monarca de países entre ellos por
ejemplo el caso interesante de Australia
que el año pasado el Primer Ministro ya
nombró para la transición ya pensando en
algún momento
romperlas o directamente con la corona
lo que es el momento el gobierno
australiano Es que la Reina Isabel había
actuado y que se le reconocía mucho su
labor respecto de como un web y luego al
frente de la corona pero esta era tiempo
para empezar a pensar en una salida
salida y cortarla no Entonces en este
contexto ya saber segunda
de la monarquía británica ya momento de
para los países empiecen ya hasta aquí y
a romper
si nos está hablando del caso de
Australia paradigmático quizás también
el de otros países como Escocia Y es que
una de las incógnitas tras la muerte de
Isabel es conocer si precisamente algún
país decidirá dejar la corona como
jefatura de estado Carlos III tiene la
suficiente fuerza como monarca de la
corona británica para mantener la unión
de la mancomunidad no solo para seguir
siendo rey de algunos países
bueno en principio uno uno cree que no
que por lo menos no tiene la misma
fortaleza británica Isabel segunda que
por supuesto fue odiada durante la
segunda mitad del siglo 20 Bajo su
reinado de la commonwealth eh sobrevivió
a nada más cada menos que al final del
sistema del mundo Bipolar por ejemplo
una organización que puede Sobreviviendo
distintos pasos a distintos fenómenos
internacionales está claro que Carlos
hoy no tiene en principio Quizás lo
puede llegar a construir pero tiene muy
poco tiempo para hacerlo porque los
reclamos son bastante bastante inmediato
para mantener unida a la comunidad
recordemos que la mancomunidad de
misiones está conformada por caos de
todo tipo está conformada por estado por
poner un ejemplo ricos como Canadá
estado
multitudinarios como India por ejemplo o
estado muy pequeños como brunéi estado
pobres este que es muy heterogénea es
una una comunidad extremadamente
y para lograr mantener tu vida es
necesario político muy particular muy
concreto es poco probable que pueda ser
además en un contexto internacional en
un contexto mundial profundamente
cambiante
impredecible No sí estamos hablando
mucho de la diversidad de países que
conforman esta como un juez pero que
conlleva exactamente formar parte de
este grupo de países Para qué sirve la
como un Wells bien a lo largo del tiempo
ha servido para para distintas facciones
para establecer y profundizar lazos
comerciales entre los miembros lazos
económicos lazos culturales para el
Reino Unido en particular
escribió para ejecutar la sociedad
bastante más multicultural hacia adentro
del Reino Unido porque favorece y
fomenta el cambio cultural entre los
miembros tiene algunos beneficios para
para los miembros sobre todo en lo que
respecta prioridad para comerciar con el
Reino Unido por supuesto
hoy en un contexto de crisis política y
de crisis económica que está viviendo
Europa en general y el Reino Unido en
particular también hace que estos
vínculos se vuelvan más complejos hay
que recordar que hoy el Reino Unido está
viviendo momentos de crisis energéticas
hasta un momento de inflación realmente
muy alta inclusive que está bordeando ya
poquitos en muchos casos superando de
crisis política también la novedad
Argentina viene de asumir la semana
pasada entonces también es importante
más todo lo que tiene que ver con el
brexit es importante ver lo que está
pasando políticamente hacia dentro del
Reino Unido Más allá de lo que sucedió
con la monarquía con con Isabel II